hey have you ever imagined that you were
instantly transported to the siberian
wilderness
i often this is legit i'm not even
joking this is not a bit
i have this running not a fantasy what's
the opposite of a fantasy a nightmare
it's not a nightmare it's something i
plan for i'm not a masochist
but just in case i do get instantly
transported to the siberian wilderness
i often wonder how i would survive
oftentimes i get transported naked
just to make it harder like hard mode
weird
teleportation accident thing amy
hates this thought experiment but what
would you do
write how you would survive in the
comments and then i will
play this game for the first time and i
will show you the right answer of how to
survive
okay cool let's do this boom oh never
mind
oh yes mind all right so first things
first uh
if you're naked in the siberian
wilderness
it is very cold in the siberian
wilderness so you need to worry about
getting warm
human beings are warm-blooded mammals we
need to stay
warm but we have internal heat
that surges out from within our core to
our extremities
except when you're in the siberian
wilderness because your extremities will
pull heat in
what is happening
uh don't jump
oh well
not best to fall backwards off of a
cliff
well i guess not best the face plants
into the ground either
okay well this is very pretty
so my first thought okay so i'm not
naked
so this is playing this on easy mode so
my thought first
is to find a hole oh [ __ ] it's cold
see that's what i said it's so cold it
was cold
well let's oh after spending the night
outside your body temperature has
dropped drastically
your hands are frozen which means you're
unable to interact with anything
stand next to any heat source to get
warm and regain full control over your
body
your body temperature can be tracked in
the top right of the screen
okay easy frostbite okay well okay well
this is a little
it's telling me exactly what i need to
do so i don't need to tell you
guys my big brain ideas
i'm not assuming that there's just going
to be uh magically
fires lurking everywhere oh
fun um but for some reason i
i kind of have a feeling that there's
gonna be kind of reminds me of the game
lixian made for me
oh hello i can crouch
what the oh no is this a horror game
i don't know no what is that
i have to be careful yeah you have to be
careful what the hell is it
your sanity is lowered by your poor
condition and fear of dangers lurking in
the forest
the lower your sanity the closer you are
to madness and further away from
survival
hallucinations are one of the first
symptoms of losing sanity harmless at
first dangerous later to be careful when
exploring for example wolves
will intimidate you and lower your
sanity wild animals may injure or kill
you
if you approach too closely that's the
other problem but you gotta
you gotta fight them because you gotta
drink their blood that's the oh
oh god oh hi
oh jesus you were eating his feet oh
no not his delicate tootsies
all right guys you have fun with that oh
my god i'm so sorry
[ __ ] why can't i go backwards oh okay um
yeah but
uh number one tactic is you cut open the
first animal you see and you dive inside
because as i learned from star wars
that's the number way one way to get
warm okay but other than that
survival is a breeze easy peasy if you
ask me
oh i just want to go home don't be such
a baby you got teleported out here you
can deal with it
you don't know when you're going to get
teleported back so you got to you got to
figure out a long-term survival plan
get used to the area
or find a local hot spring finally
goddamn that is convenient body
temperature
changes according to ambient temperature
this is this is goddamn delightful oh
ah oh
now that's nice oh i guess i'm
doing this now
oh that feels much better
hey this is my oh that's a lot of them
run i will run i am running now
look where comes my survival when do i
get a choice about
this oh they come oh they're coming oh
they're coming
okay hang on i didn't expect this to be
as urgent in the beginning of this
but i'll do my best you can't get me i
feel like i'm doing a lot of running
because i ran from that bear and now i'm
running from these wolves
[Music]
yeah what's up [ __ ] come down here
health bar represents physical condition
got it
all right whatever man bang my leg
what did i do sprained the ankle oh
little [ __ ] baby i got a broken
foot you think that's gonna bother me
man everything sure is convenient in
this area who would have a cabin out in
the siberian wilderness
nobody except for vicious you don't want
to be messing with those
don't trust anybody else in the siberian
wilderness once you've been teleported
there
they might be out to kill you
it's a horror game it's a horror game
this is a horror game i have to pull
myself together
i have to pull myself there's a horror
game god damn okay
hello this is so like the game that
lexia made
hello oh roy
ah perfect great stuff
actually this is surprisingly great
stuff i will admit
med kit everything you pick up goes
straight into your inventory the size of
your inventory depends on your equipment
you can drag and drop items in the quick
slot okay
inventory ah look at me handsome man
much better much bitter this cold is
killing me
well you know maybe you should be warmer
fireplaces and shelters are ready to use
you only need to add
fuel okay
[Music]
all right light up
fuel light
good thing i have that is this thing
still
on i should save the battery for later
is what things still on what are you
talking about
okay oh flashlight oh cool for one day
oh oh okay you know what yeah i'll go to
sleep
[ __ ] trip there's a [ __ ] trip
[Music]
others you know maybe you shouldn't
worry about others maybe you should
worry about yourself
oftentimes being selfish is in the best
way but when you're in the suburian will
and you've been teleported there out of
your will randomly you gotta worry about
you and you alone
terrible night well i mean you're not
dead so
i have to go back there and get my stuff
well we don't have to
we might not have to anybody here
retrieve your gear okay i don't know how
important that's gonna be
where's my gear is there even a quick
path to it
apparently can i slide ah damn this
looked like i could slide
oh well oh you mean if i did just do
you mean if i were just taking a left
turn i would have made it to my cabin
immediately i'm some kind of an
idiot oh hello there you are
all right canteen quickest way to quench
your thirst is eating snow take note
that it replenishes your fluid slightly
and lowers your body temperature
you can find natural sources of water as
well be careful with hot springs as
their waters are harmful to drink
[ __ ] it's empty ah damn although there
is plenty of snow around here
there is plenty of snow there's
genius snow to eat it oh yeah
all right man more
all right but it's fine because i can
just go to that
i could just go to that hot spring and
get warm again also if i'm running
shouldn't i also build up some heat
i feel like i would but then again i
don't really know because i'm an idiot
and i haven't exactly accounted for the
fact that i might be teleported to the
siberian wilderness
and not be naked all of my plans were
kind of hinging on me being naked at
this point
so my best bet is just to get naked that
would be my best
bet it doesn't look good
you think this might have been you maybe
this was you
instinct mode hell yeah oh
finally we're on the right page here
okay
wolves are extremely dangerous and will
kill you with these avoid them at all
costs
you don't feel hopeful you are
progressively losing sanity
excellent it just keeps getting worse
yeah it does doesn't
i hope they're okay ah nah this don't
look good for nobody man
this looks very bad man there's a lot of
hot springs around here ah
very nice well i guess i should just let
myself
warm up as much as i can right pretty
toasty
ah i know it's probably sulfurous like
super poisonous water but hey it feels
good and that's all that matters
okay why am i still cold come on come on
neutral come on man all right it's good
enough you know it's good enough i need
to get to my
backpack whatever's in my backpack
i mean it might just be space who knows
but
you careful careful careful schmearful
that's what i always say
i can't grab under there oh you can't
climb okay well that's unfortunate for
me
hop oh come on oh come on oh come on
okay here we go here we go all right
what was that about my friends or
something like that a bear
or whatnot or what have you what else
was looking up there
boom i supposed to look at these
but i already look at these uh i guess
i'm supposed to follow him
whoa what is that potato
hell yeah oh what do we have here
is that a carrot oh my god i'm a genius
see that's what you also got to do when
you get teleported to the siberian
wilderness
you got to look for haters and carrots
get them they're everywhere
survival is easy if you know what
potatoes and carrots look like
i'm assuming that this is leading me
somewhere not where the bear trail ends
here
yeah i wonder what happened probably
reached the other side but now
the bridge doesn't look very stable what
about this suggests that they made it to
the other side
yet what in the world i think i saw
their camp on the way
i didn't see [ __ ] what are you talking
about
don't put words in my mouth don't put
sights in my eyes don't do anything from
me
hmm funny how i was just running this
way
nice nice you can find different types
of food which affect your hunger
differently okay about time to head back
well i don't know about that man i need
to eat something oh good thing i got
this
food how do i get more uh firewood
when do i get an axe i could just rip
these things down with my bare hands i
am very strong
someone tells me they won't go with that
one why is this capturing like
what is with it what is the [ __ ]
games
not capturing well these days i got this
new computer so that it would do its job
but why why is it not the [ __ ] is the
deal
i don't get it my dudes i don't get it
why
why does it not just
capture correctly why does it not just
capture correctly
why not why
i've been dealing with this for so many
years trying
so many different ways for it to not
[ __ ] miss
frames due to rendering lag
oh i'm gonna lose my mind i'm gonna lose
my mind guys i'm gonna lose my mind i'm
gonna lose my mind
why does this happen why does this
happen obvious
oh yes obvious why does this happen
i'm okay when i'm looking on my screen i
see smooth
buttery images and yet look look hey
97 well that's why i'm getting smooth as
butter
my cpu isn't doing that but look
90. oh good at that how about that
okay hey what's up guys i'm sorry to
interrupt the video here but this is all
part of winter survival
getting the right frame rates on your
frickin ovs recordings
that you haven't changed in years i have
not changed in a long long time
i like obs i do i don't have a problem
with obs except for these
scenarios you know when you're capturing
games and you know that's just the main
part of my job is uh uh capturing games
and you'd think that it would be able to
do that flawlessly but no
as it turns out no it doesn't work out
that way
because it just doesn't save enough my
graphics card it is chugging
literally as hard as it could possibly
chug 98 percent
chug-a-lug speed for making this game
look
and i appreciate it for that but it's
only saving two percent
for obvious and i don't understand why
look look look why
why why why why doesn't obs get the
minimum of what it needs
why why why don't why why doesn't it
why why does this happen
why does this happen i just want to know
why it happens
i right now have vertical sync on i have
nvidia to frame rate limit at 60 frames
per second and it's not doing it
clearly it's not doing it then the gpu
is like i've got room to sprint
baby it's 11 but why does it need 11
this is rendering the video on the cpu
i have been struggling with this for far
too long maybe i've done
some bad things
i don't think i'm a bad person but
you know i
think that maybe
[Music]
maybe this is what i deserve you know
hey what better time than in the middle
of an
of a normal gameplay video to have a
little pow-wow here
have a little pow-wow i'm gonna get back
to the game don't worry i'm gonna get
back to the game but i just wanted to
say
i know the offline schedule has not been
normal but that's just because i've been
busier than i've ever been in my entire
life but it's not a bad thing it's a
good thing there's a lot of exciting
stuff going on but
i'm only one guy and all i want
is for obs to capture properly that's
that's really
all i want all i've ever wanted
[Music]
is for robbie has to capture properly
all right now in order to play this game
properly
because it just started lagging again
i'm going to turn the graphics down
now that seems weird but i i have to
oh and the it's still not right
[Music]
obvious isn't even here
restart
[Music]
are we capturing smoove yes
we freed up just enough just enough of
the gpu so that would
we did it guys we did it here we'll
prove it
we're gonna epic and then we're gonna
get choppy
it's choppy and we're going low
and we're good we did it
oh it looks so bad oh my god it looks so
bad
oh i can't even continue my game oh
god
[Applause]
i will get back to where we were
oh it looks so bad oh no
oh yeah
oh god it's so bad
but the frame rates are good guys
i'm gaming all the way back in 2003.
oh my god who would game this one
i know a lot of people do game this way
but my god oh
no i've regressed
oh yes what have you done this
i'm actually sad i'm actually sad oh
god i don't know if i can guys i don't
know if i can
i don't know if i can do this i've lost
all willpower
is this better is it could this possibly
be better
is it possibly better can i go to medium
at least can i do medium can i get away
with medium i think we're still running
at good frame rates
okay we're okay we're gonna go one notch
higher come on if we can just get one
more notch
okay oh the difference between high oh
oh oh
are we no we're lagging all right okay
all right
no lens flares no reflection no bloom
no ambient clue this is what we deserve
this is what we deserve
this is all i deserve obs i get it i'm
now down where at your level obs
i get it i can't even see what i'm
looking at this
blood i can't see anything
oh no that feels much better it feels
much worse it feels
so much worse for those wolves i
literally can't tell run
oh okay maybe it's best if the wolves
kill me
maybe you know maybe that would be
better but you know what wolves
just kill me just kill me
don't look at me like that kill me
well this took a turn for the better i
think
i think instead of winter survival
simulator that was just
mark loses his sanity simulator except
instead of a simulator it's real for me
but for you it's you
get to simulate what it happens when i
lose my sanity altogether so
just gonna
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed winter survival
simulator it was a good game
uh this was just the demo so the full
experience will be coming out
sometime this year maybe when that comes
out i'll give it another try but i think
this was a fun adventure
i think that it really opened up my eyes
to the possibilities of what
i could do if i find myself in the
winter scenario
so i will keep that in mind and i trust
lixian to make this into a very
very enjoyable experience for everyone
alexian uh make sure this is
it's a great video right
good i love obs
thank you for watching and as always i
will see you in the next one
bye bye
[Music]
you